for DC Comics fans hopes have been
growing that Robin Batman's legendary
parlor and crime-fighting might get his
own solo movie someday after all one of
brothers is hard at work adapting tons
of DC Comics characters for appearances
in its shared cinematic universe if
they're gonna give Aquaman his own movie
no characters really out of the question
at this point and Robins actually one of
the most popular and visible DC Comics
characters ever it's tough to go very
far without seeing our favorite spandex
sidekick on TV whether it's Teen Titans
go Young Justice or in DC's animated
movies like Batman versus Robin and
Justice League vs Teen Titans or even as
one of the featured characters and 27
teams Lego Batman movie it's better he's
even been named the second best sidekick
ever right behind Ed McMahon but just
don't get too excited
while Robin related miracles can happen
Batman did eventually let him wear pants
the truth is that DC has probably
already killed the chance of a Robert
movie and it didn't even require a
crowbar he's already dead perhaps the
most direct reason DC isn't going to
make a Robin movie is that well
the carrot has already been killed
Robins DC movie verse death was first
hinted at in Batman vs Superman and then
mentioned outright to the Suicide Squad
now Batman goes through Robins like
tissues so it's entirely possible that
Warner Brothers could pick up from one
of the nearly half dozen other
characters who've been the boy or girl
Wonder but that inflicts its own set of
headaches which Robin to choose while
Batman has pretty much always been Bruce
Wayne with only a few brief exceptions
being Robin is basically the equivalent
of a superhero internship there was Dick
Grayson Jason Todd Tim Drake Stephanie
Brown and Damian Wayne who's actually
Bruce Wayne's murder-happy son each
choice would bring a certain amount of
baggage and convoluted backstory and no
matter the choice it'll probably annoy
some segments of comic book readers
whose favorite Robin wasn't picked to
much backstory but let's pretend that
Warner Brothers decides that movie
Batman does need a movie Robin the fact
that Robins already been killed before
the events of DC's new movies
complicates things even further is the
dead Robin Jason Todd mirror
his comic book death at the Joker's
hands was it dick the first Robin or has
he already graduated to solo hero status
as Nightwing what's the best way to
introduce a living version of Robin into
DC's movies without first delving into
the twists and turns of continuity
bringing in a new Robin would be
complicated enough in a Batman movie
don't hold your breath on a solo outing
boy wonder how the fans really feel
perhaps the most direct and blunt reason
that there won't be a Robin movie is
that well plenty of people may not
actually want it after all and there's
proof when people talk about how Jason
Todd was killed by the Joker that's only
half true
in fact the Joker had some accomplices
5343 comic-book fans to be exact in 1988
DC Comics put Jason into mortal jeopardy
at the end of an issue then included a 1
900 number you know the kind that cost
money to cool to decide his fate even
though only 72 more fans voted to kill
him off than those who called to keep
him alive the fact that there wasn't an
overwhelming response for him to live
kind of say something about how much
fans seemed to actually care about Robin
in general and that's not all think
about the fact that there have been
eight live-action film starring Batman
since 1989 and only two of them Batman
Forever and Batman and Robin widely
known as the crappiest two that fans
hate the most featured the Boy Wonder
Christopher Nolan's Batman trilogy
performs just fine without the added
benefit of robbing and no shoehorning of
Robin reference into the end of Dark
Knight Rises doesn't count you should
use your name I like that name Robin
teamwork finally and most importantly
the idea of a Robin solo movie is pretty
much impossible when you think about it
since it's pretty much baked into his
character from the start
Robin just works better as part of a
team whether it be in the dynamic duo or
in a larger group like the Teen Titans
sidekicks are usually just reflections
of the primary hero so what would a
Robin movie be without Batman Robin's
first solo comic series in the nineties
shows Batman sending Tim Drake off to
France to learn kung-fu
because everyone knows the best ninjas
come from Paris Robin's next solo series
left him in Gotham City to fight the
Joker alone or Batman took off to Rio de
Janeiro with a Robin solo movie somehow
contrived to get Batman out of the
picture in the same way just picture it
uh hi commissioner it's me Robin sorry
Batman's on vacation this week so he can
solve the horrible serial murderers
plaguing the city but hey at least we'll
get a good tan what Oh surely you you
must be Justin no I'm not Justin sory
but like I'll totally do the voice if
you think that'll help I am the knight I
am
[Music]
catastrophic this rated be surprising if
Robin ever shows up in the DC extended
universe at all let alone in a starring
role in his own superhero flick then
again someone thought it was a good idea
to make a movie about Superman knockoff
steel starring a rapping basketball
player
so really anything's possible thanks for
watching click at the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]